samedi ça va le grec regarde ces ballons
qui fit et à l'eau ouais bon je suis
créé toutes les oules grecque
valencia tic porte maillot une eu une
asiatique porte maillot sérieux j'arrête
avec les gonzesses
christine est tombé sur mon portable
hier soir très chaud à la maison en
parlant de maisons cuisse il a appelé
faut pas que tu oublies dû jouer sa date
de naissance hiver 3,17 suffit pas du
jeu 3,17 manar buffalo jours de fête et
mam ollier vous devez pas être nombreux
sur ce coup là
non je bouge plus choqué c'est médical
je sais alors doucement et des mots
magiques
vous avez une carte non mais
heureusement je compte y est alors pas
de mouvements brusques quand vous
baissez les genoux toujours erreur
surtout très importante voire beaucoup
d'eau voilà merci je m'appelle sandra
enchanté semble bonne journée aussi bon
s'il vous plaît monsieur je peux
travailler sérieusement ici aller en
voiture mais dans mon bureau
[Musique]